hi my name is Marcus venoms ik a member
of the image processing and signal
processing team and my talk title is a
neural networks for images the same
title as last year but it's a different
content essentially it's part two about
image specification but about how to
generate images and how to do
unsupervised learning
welcome to the talk about neural
networks for images this talk is meant
for people that don't that do know
Mathematica but don't know neural
networks essentially so it's a little
bit different than the usual talks you
get here because usually if you gets
let's say go to finite element methods
we assume that you know what finite
element methods is all about and we'll
just tell you how to do in Mathematica
but my conception or my impression was
that lots of people know mathematically
at this conference but no not so much
about your network so we're just doing
the whole thing a little bit around and
I'll talk about not so much about the
framework this will be done in other
talks during this conference but I'll
talk a bit more about neural networks
it's specifically those that apply to
images maybe a quick question up front
has who has trained in your network in
the audience well okay maybe that
concept was not so good 50 50 we'll see
okay so this was the first topic of this
outline or what this talk is not about
so it's not about the framework as such
it's about the networks being used I
will quickly mention classifiers because
I've built on them but as I said up
front in the abstract of this talk I
will try to go beyond the ordinary
classifiers that we have in image
processing and Niue and networks neural
networks that tell you oh this is a cat
this is a dog and so on but the next
topic I'll be addressing are generator
so those neural networks that generate
images and how it's being done then I'll
talk about autoencoders encoders that
work without having a super vision
without having text data so the machine
itself tries to figure out how the
structure house statistics is about in
the data structure of the image this
also applies to variational autoencoders
though they have an extra twist I'll be
talking about and then some what the
holy grail nowadays are generative
adversarial networks or in short gans
and this will be the
last topic I'll be addressing and the
unit's this will move upwards a little
bit that's wrong order here in this
outline so this is roughly what I try to
cover so it's quite a bit and I by the
way work here on version 11.3 I try to
not not to be bright this morning I'd
like to keep it safe and so all of this
if you have 11.3 should be possible on
your computer and secondly what I do
though is just in very few cases our use
of GPU so what you see up here is an
external GPU attached to my laptop if
you have desktop with a GPU it should be
already inside and that allows me to
speed up a little bit the training which
is somewhat almost mandatory if you'd
like to experiment a little bit and see
what's how things are working so quickly
what I won't talk about our classifiers
classifiers especially in image
processing usually take an image in
which is here on the orange side lots of
neurons that are activated according to
the pixel activity that they are
assigned to and then that activational
works or is being transmitted through
the network and at the end you'd like to
have essentially just a few neurons that
are being assigned to certain classes
and depending on the activity of those
neurons you have then a class
identification this is here a very small
convolutional Network you just have a
few convolutional layers with the
corresponding real oohs then I flattened
the whole thing a fully connected layer
another fully connected layer softmax
that's it and then it's always
interesting to see if you do experiments
how many parameters do you have to train
because that roughly tells you the
complexity or the complexity of the
function that you'd essentially like to
fit because training a network is very
much like fitting a function except that
you are working with functions with lots
and lots of parameters in this case this
very small network already has 150,000
parameters and if I were now to start
running this okay this is already this
system does not appear okay so
doesn't is a typical thing that happens
I can't train this in real time so you
have to bear with me I did play it safe
though I did save the stuff up front
which also doesn't seem to work now this
is it simple to protect well it seemed
to work
yeah but it takes five minutes so and
it's just a few things and I can do this
way and it's as soon as I leave my desk
bring it over here stuff like that
happens it's unfortunately directory
that will crashing machine so this is
unfortunately Apple doesn't go along
very well with NVIDIA I need an NVIDIA
GPU and they make it look slightly
difficult for you to work on this okay
so okay so I'm back in business I did
load all these train networks but
beforehand because this kind of stuff
usually happens when you demonstrate
something so okay when you train this
you see essentially if you have training
data and test data you usually see two
lines the red line is basically the loss
the of the network that you have to find
that try to that's being minimized and
then the blue line which is a more
important line basically tells you if
this training that you achieve here if
that also translates to test data so two
data that hasn't been seen by the
training algorithm and if that keeps
going down that's fine once it stays up
here you're essentially overfitting and
it's not so great but this this is still
in the good ballpark yeah you
essentially have the error rate which is
way down there so this is classifier
seems to work and I can nicely apply it
and I can get the accuracy the error and
so forth and last but not least the
confusion metric so so that that was a
business up very early days when we were
shipping image identify which is
essentially the same content concept
just a little bit bigger more images
larger images a larger network okay but
in order to have more fun you can also
generate images
with newer networks and essentially all
you do is and why turn the thing around
basically have a network that starts
with neurons that depict classes or
certain types of images and then you
deconvolve or actually it's a transposed
convolution so a network that becomes
bigger and bigger and at the end the
neurons in your network represent the
pixels in your image and so if I were to
generate now generate a network that
looks like this you have basically a
unit vector layer going in which just
activates ten different neurons and then
you have a linear layer fully connected
layer leaving increasing the activity
over 256 neurons then up to 512 neurons
and then you reshape it into an image
and have a deconvolution up all the way
to 28 times 28 pixels you again have
pretty much the same network as before
and but just in an inverse matter again
153 153 thousand neurons to Train and if
I now train this which I assume doesn't
work just testing a still doesn't work
and still ok it's this is not reading so
I have to get this by hand
then you have generator and that
generator allows you to just put in
numbers initial activations and
essentially at the very bottom let me
scroll this up a little bit you then get
an output okay so the idea is you can
generate images you can classify images
you can just basically hook it up
together and that gives you what's
called an auto encoder so the idea is to
have a network that analyzes the
incoming image and then produces an
outgoing image based on that the nice
thing about an auto encoder is also that
it can be used for unsupervised learning
unsupervised learning means you
basically don't have images that comes
with the tech saying this is a cat this
is a dog or whatever but just images of
cats of dogs of zebras whatever and in
order to create a loss now you just
don't have to compare the incoming image
with attack here somewhere in the middle
but what you do is you just say okay I
for example if if this an autoencoder I
want to make sure that this autoencoder
reproduces the image so that the
original image coming in also comes out
and this is a little bit tough because
you have here what's called bottleneck
he basically makes the Machine try to
condense the information in the image so
that it can be passed across these few
neurons and then be rebuilt and so
basically you urge the network here to
find some kind of representation that is
pretty informative about the incoming
image and you can also increase the
difficulty a little bit by for example
saying okay the images that I sent in
also corrupt in the sense that I put
noise on them or that I cut away a few
things so that the network learns to
undo this corruption here I built an
audience with just five neurons in the
middle so it's not one-to-one here this
is just depicting the concept and so
this would be the auto encoder again you
can see you encode something then you
just have five neurons you decode it and
the loss is basically a comparison of
the input with the output oh sorry yeah
the input coming here and the output
coming from the decoder
feeding into the loss function here and
producing a loss so again I don't waste
tons by the way just as the order of
magnitude it takes about a minute or two
to train on a GPU or so in principle and
could that do live could do this life
but with just 20 minutes or 25 minutes
to go I rather not waste this time
result and what I get now is an
autoencoder net I can extract from the
audience or depart which I do here by a
net extract and then on top of it I have
to attach a net encoder which basically
converts an image an incoming image into
an array and extract you the decoder
card and then I can play with it for
example I can say well take the encoder
apply to a digit like here and it
automatically generates now the activity
of those five neurons in the middle of
the order into otay otay a decoder auto
encoder and then I can take that code
and reproduce the image and you see well
it's not exactly identical but the
essence is there roughly the thickness
of the digits and the type of digit and
of course I can combine this I can
combine encoder and decoder and benefit
you have here is now that this encoder
and decoder
since it tries to read out the essence
of the digit is pretty robust against
noise so if I add now noise to these
digits quite substantial noise down here
I can just send it through the encoder
and decoder and automatically retain the
digits and please forgive me that I'm
doing this all on very simple examples
that way you can play with it of course
this all applies to larger images as
well okay then since you now have
automatically learned something with an
auto encoder it can actually take that
unsupervised knowledge that you have
gained and applied to some other task
for example you could take the first two
layers of the encoder that you just
generated with the auto encoder
and use it as a feature instructor
feature extraction layer in an other
classifier for example the benefit of
that is that in essence I only have to
reattach a new kind of last few layers
to classify the features coming in and
that can be done with much fewer data
points than I usually would have to use
so what I do here is I create a
classifier parts or the end part of a
network I just quickly look how much
information that's needed to be trained
and I you can see the classifier back
here
it's basically easy to train it just has
two thousand five hundred and seventy
parameters in contrast to the hundred
and fifty that the entire encoder just
had a minute ago so what I can do is I
can combine this into a classifier I
take the first few layers of the auto
encoder that I just trained without
labels and now I just attach the few
classifier layers and then I can put
this into a net train command and we now
retrains the whole thing but just with a
thousand data points so instead of 50
thousand digits to run I just need to
get the order of a thousand and what you
also see here is I make sure that all
the first few six layers are not being
trained by setting the learning rate
multiply to zero only the remaining ones
are being trained and that then runs a
little bit and so I have to get here
again and that way I get a classifier
like this which I have trained like this
you see you do over fit because I have
very few points to work with but I can
applied and it just works fine and I get
down to an error rate of less than 5%
and I won't waste our time I just for
the completeness sake I did also attach
here the whole thing without using the
pre trained
class future extractor and see how how
well I do and you can see that you
basically gain one to two
and ever rate because of this transfer
learning because of the transfer
detaching from the order encoded the
feature layers and reattaching them here
so let me skip this because time is of
the essence here
so now another auto encoder it's
slightly different it's called the
variational auto in decoder and the
evolutional benefit here is the
following what we had before was
basically an auto encoder that just took
an image somehow compressed the data
into a few neurons and then was
reconstructing the data again but there
was no influence and how it would
construct those five neurons or how it
would encode it could do it in any world
anyway it would like to and if you would
like to maintain a certain consistency a
certain nice feature space here in in
the bottleneck you have to impose a few
extra constraints and the constraint
that an variational auto encoder tries
to impose here on the bottleneck is that
the statistics of the activity of these
neurons should be a Gaussian activity
ocean distribution so the activity
should be around zero and to make sure
that the statistics behaves pretty much
like a normal distribution and now the
question is how do you do that because
that's the tricky part
well the decoder part is essentially the
same as we had before you have a linear
layer then you reshape it and you have a
deconvolution layer and so forth the
tricky part comes with the encoder
because the encoder has to produce kind
of random variables or latent activities
that have this normal distribution and
in order to obtain that you do not
create just a layer of activities but
you create just the properties of a
Gaussian distribution which is you
create the activities of the
intermittent neurons by a mean and by a
standard deviation or in this case a
logarithmic a logarithm or the standard
deviation just because it involves less
computation essentially and these are
the two informations that you generate
and then from these two you generate a
random number according to a normal
distribution and feed that into the
decoder so it's a kind of a random
process that is being driven or stirred
by the encoder and all of this i/o this
is something you probably have to do
then once you get the notebook which
will be uploaded by the way right after
the talk you can generate this Victoria
earth or a this variational auto encoder
and well if I train that and its
training takes too long I'll load it in
quickly
I get this encoder and the encoder has
now the nice property that it tries to
generate kind of a continuous manifold
of properties that's the advantage of a
variational auto encoder because of the
statistics that you impose you have to
make sure that neighboring properties
are located next to each other so the
encoder essentially generates mean and
the standard deviation you create the
mean you put that into the decoder and
that generates then an output digit like
here in this case the digit six and the
whole thing doesn't look like much but
if you then generate a whole array or
the whole manifold of activities in
these two just two neurons by the way in
the bottleneck you see that you generate
a kind of a continuous distribution of
digits like here's the center of seven
that slowly changes into the digits one
eight zero six nine only the four
problem needs a little bit more training
it's very much like the nine and now it
also allows you to just if you move
around in this space to basically
interpolate between features you don't
interpolate between pixels anymore okay
this by the way is very nice if you were
to estimate a pose I'd say you have lots
of pictures of people posing and in
order to identify the parameters of the
poses this is how you could go about all
right I just quickly want to mention one
network that's by the way not yet in the
repository it's a unit a unit has a
certain resemblance okay there we go
as a certain resemblance with Audion
if you come on if you look at it
basically it's like an auto encoder that
encode certain features then has a
connection then codes even further and
so forth here we go
so this is the input and essentially you
decompose an image further and further
and further until you get to a very low
resolution and then you Rhea
reconstructed again and essentially this
is great for translating images
translating means for example if you
have an image that I'd like to segment
and I'd like to translate the image from
an image into a segmentation and this
you can for example do with this
particular Network by running it through
this net and well maybe I don't activate
everything I'll just show you the result
since I don't have GPU support here and
it allows you then to segments for
example microscopy images automatically
without having to teach your machine all
the details all the features to look for
and so forth segmentation means
basically if you have an image and you'd
like to segment the foreground versus
the background for example here to for
example segment all the cells to get the
outline of a cell that that means you
may want to call it layer as well to
just find here it's going to be uploaded
where all the notebooks of the talks
will be on what is it called impossible
right exactly
so this will take another half an hour
because I was working with version 12
and I decided to switch shortly
beforehand so that's why okay and last
but not least let me quickly mention
against because they are the hot topic
now against in a way also train
generators basically
you have a generating network like here
but if you don't have labels what you
could at least instead of just doing an
ordinary loss you basically also have
Network which functions as a
discriminator and then discriminator
basically has a following task I
generate images with the generator
starting with some random input and
these images have to look very much like
alike like another set of images and
then the discriminator has to tell is
this now a fake image was it a real
image and both of these networks have to
be to basically play against each other
which means that the generator has to a
forge in images and tries to get better
and better and the discriminator has to
basically get better and better to tell
apart what's forged and what's not and
so this you can also run in Mathematica
but this takes a little too long so I'll
skip through the code here and at the
end you end up with a generator and this
unfortunately is always very hard to
train and you get images like this here
I should probably train a little longer
where the out-of-the-blue basically the
generator learns how to Fortune eight
nine zero five and you slowly get to the
point where the images that you make up
look almost identical to the ones that
you have as a comparison and this is
basically what's behind those cyclic
against that we have in the net
repository and the next talk will be
addressing those if you have two
unpaired sets of images like set of
photos and a set of paintings that
roughly depict the same thing but of
different style then you can generate
mappings that take you for example from
a photo to a painting and back and there
you have now again a adversarial Network
basically a discriminator one
discriminator trying to figure out if
this is a photo or not so if this
mapping screws up and converts am a
painting of Monet into something that
should look like a photo but doesn't
this discriminator would kick in vice
versa if G Maps something to Y and it
doesn't look good this discriminator
would kick in and
order to make this psycho I also make
sure that whatever I generate here has a
certain resemblance with what's at the
origin because if I combine concatenate
G and F then I should get something out
that resembles the original image so a
little bit like an autoencoder
and these are Gans and just to end here
on an interesting note I'll just load
your image so this is a painting off oh
gosh what's going on here
okay sorry it's blowing it I don't know
what image dimensions doesn't work right
now so this is a killer I'm sorry for
that but basically you can create images
like that and then they are being
converted to photos and vice versa and I
will skip this now because this will
also pop up in the next talk by tusita
and Matteo and so you'll get an
impression of how these works as well
alright
this brings me to an end thanks for
attending and
[Applause]